es gibt's ja nicht du bist doch der
Freddy oder du bist doch der W aus der
6b ja ganz
genau ja Mens
W du wie lang ist das jetzt her also 50
locker spinnst du Zeit vergeht aber gut
schaust aus ja du und was hast jetzt
Stream in den ganzen Jahren
wahrscheinlich Abitur studiert Frau acht
Kinder
fast also Abi habe ich dann doch nicht
gemacht dafür Party noch und nö frirat
dre geschieden mitm Geldverdiener habe
ich nicht so gehabt aber mit Geld
ausgeben ja dannute spielschuen ohne
dann zer und was soll ich jetzt bin
Verbrecher Verbrecher richtiger also
keine großen Sachen eher so mittel klein
Einbrüche bisschen he klar warum nicht
jeder s machen was kan eben so schaut
aus ja und deswegen m die dich jetzt
auch bitten dass du mir de Geld
verstehst schon Job ist Job oh da aber
jetztade was diese Uhr aber ist aber
schon schön ja die war auch nicht ganz
billig du bist bes aber die gern hab ja
bra do nicht drüber
reden das ist aber sch also wirklich ist
aber jetzt kein Geschenk von deiner Frau
oder so od na na die ist von meine
Kollegen von der
Wache von der we ja ja ich habe doch
damals mittlere Reife ich gemacht und
dann bin ich auf polizeis
super und dann z jah in der Uniform dann
bin ich Kriminalpolizei inzwischen bin
ich beim raubdezanat das gibt's Respekt
deswegen kannst mal die Uhr schon mal
wieder geben ja und dar bei der
polizeiin total gut es ist nicht der
tort gell aber du da passieren schon
auch Sachen aber gut das brauch ich dir
nicht verzen wirklich also in unserer
Branche da erlebt schon
Sachen rolben
bitte gesagt Job ist Job ja ganz ein
prof
ja und mein Geldbeutel
bitte den H jetzt fast
vergessen danke sehr schön so und ein
personales wei die ja du da aber auf das
Foto sch bitte nicht ich bin da nicht so
gut
[Gelächter]
getroffen so jetzt wenn die
frei ja ich pass auf das nicht so du
magst selber ich ger bisschen
fest du ich sag mit M uns unbedingt eter
treffen absolut ich mE du we wo jetzt W
die nächste
Zeit
oh D die Lehrerin
die
KN gar nichts mehr
[Applaus]
K